So.. I didn't film last night because uhh, I didn't wanna get a strike but I came home at 4:30
Just.. drenched in blood
went in here... Just... Look at this fuckin' shit
Oh my GOD
That thing was SO GROSS
I had to wear it for so long and it was so... UGH
UGHGHGHGH
UGHH
DISGUSTING
Can you imagine if Marzia woke up and she saw me like that? *laugh*
I probably should have scared her, but... DIDNT WANNA GET A STRIKE!
There's even blood on my pillow.. Seriously.
Yesterday I didn't get to show you guys, but I bought some cool stuff.
Oh shit
I really like this jacket!
It's surprisingly cold in L.A.
I think it looks really good (yes it does pewds)
I bought some candles.. Yeah I'm that level of hipster right now...
Like, if someone told me that, like, two years ago "Hey, by the way, in two years you'll buy fucking candles unironically,"
I would wanna punch myself
My self from two years ago would wanna punch myself *confused look*
*SNIFFS CANDLE SEXILY*
BUT THEY SMELL SO GOOD THOUGH!
Also got a very nice shirt THAT I CAN'T WEAR because I have to wear this one!
Another nice shirt that I can't wear.. ANOTHER NICE ONE.. AND a pair of pants!
I think I'll wear them today actually
*PEWDS YOU TEASE*
Oh yeah! These are cool!
Mini drone! It was a huge investment, but now I can finally be Casey Neistat
Once I get these drone shots going, oof, BIRDABO is gonna go to the next level!
Did I.. I... I almost dabbed. I almost dabbed.
I've actually never dabbed in my life.
Then I bought this robot thing that I wanted to test out as well
So apparently this bot is able to understand, like, programming with lines
OH MY GOD!
Oh my god!
Wow!
Yeah I'm 12, what do you.. what do you want?
So apparently this one has a camera on it.. I can film?
I don't know
WOAH!
Woah! YEAH, WADUP! WADUP. WADUP.
Why am I doing this?
You wish you had this.. drone Casey! You wish you had this drone!
Look at this, this is COOL
Let me turn it around...
It doesn't turn around.
Well let me.. back up..
It's so cool, let's go outside
I wanna apologize in advance because I'm gonna be super busy today. That's why I'm just fuckin' about right now
WADUP PEEPS?? WADUP PEEPS???
That's cool man, that's really cool, that's really cool
PERFECT LANDING
OH, OH SHIT DAWG
I might actually bring this out to just take some actual shots, if this camera actually works
*MUSICS*
Alright, I'm at Michaels, he forgot his sweater.. He knows im coming, but what I'm gonna do is,
I'm gonna unlock one of his windows, so that next time, I can sneak up on him... *laughs*
post man!
BAAHH!
How ya doin' buddy? Michael: hey, good morning!
Bye, Michael! Byeeee! *Michael singing in distance*
Fuckin' hate that guy
I wanted BIRDABO to be (an) honest vlog, not like a lot of vloggers who pretend that everything is so happy and
everything is so fun, and then one year later, it turns out they want to kill themself, you know
I.. I'm not feeling great.
I was stressed out before I went to L.A., I was thinking L.A. would make me feel better and less stressed,
uh, I've never been this stressed in a long time, and I don't.. I rarely get stressed.
It's just, being here... I don't sleep enough, I don't have time for myself
I sound like such a fuckin' pussy, I'm sorry
It's just.. when I don't have time to do my own things, I get REALLY stressed out
It's not a lot, like, I just wanna spend some time with Marzia and I wanna be able to exercise.
That's like, two important things to me.
And if I don't get to do that, umm, I don't feel very good. I get stressed out and..
Now, I- I- I gotta do these things today and I won't have time to vlog, that's why I was doing all this shit this morning.
Just to get some stuff for the vlog which is fine, but uhh.. I know- I'm not saying:
"UH- YOU UH- UH YOU SHOULD STOP VLOGGIN'."
I love the vlog. Vlogging is the best part of me being in LA so far.
So don't take- don't take that away from me.
i am just i think... i need some time to saddle in LA i think
I haven't been able to do that
Alright now im gonna drive for one fucking hour
Everyone in LA pretends that they live in the same city when they're not for some reason
(laughs)
If you are one hour no you are not in the same city, you are fucking far away
(some music)
(some cool music)
(Damn handsome)
Marzia made me luuunch!
yea!
thank you
you're welcome
i also wanna show you something really cool
yea
im finally a real vlogger
(laughs)
it films!
really?
yeh, its recording right now
what?
yea
now we are going for ashf..- uhh
photoshoot. i cant say what it is,
but i asked for a toad to be there.
What're you gonna do if they don't give it to you?
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna go full Oprah
Wheres my TOAD!?
Is that what she does it?
Toads for everyone!
i guess i should have expected it to be a wierd shoot when i saw that house
but... hey, i got slippy!
slippy is mine
finally! i miss you so much, slippy
dramatic music! Okay, we're at Michael's place
i left his window unlocked this morning. Slippy is here, Ken is here
we are gonna sneak in, and we're gonna give that bitch a strike!
(BUSTED)
God damnit! Michael, are you wearing the shirt?
He's wearing the damn shirt... GOD DAMNIT.
fuck you, you ass hole
whatever shut up, shut up
get him!
cmon cmon cmon not again!
NOT AGAIN
is this milk?
no dont!
No you can't do that!
Ken:  What're you lookin' at me for?  Pewds: SWITCH!       3 2 1 go!
Get him! Get him! Get his nipples!
Don't resist, don't resist! Get his nipples...
Michael: well it's not too bad.. Like this is bad.. This was from Ethan (papa bless) he made another one
thank you very much
i love dick
michael you love dick?
this is horrible, seriously, you need to do something about that Michael
You cant walk around like that
got him! got him!
(high five )
hell yea
yea yea
finally happened
there was a girl jumping in front of our gate
trying- with her phone trying to take pictures
and i shut that shit down
And then the mom comes in the picture
Ken: he made her cry
I did make her- apparently I made her cry, but her mom was there
And she's like BEWDIBABOO, and I'm like, well you should know better.
and.. I feel bad, but you can't come to my house with a phone
And you're an adult.. If you come with your daughter, like.. I don't know what to say.
Ken: what're you gonna do if you come here tomorrow and there are like 20 people outside?
I'll shut that shit down, I'll shut that shit down anyway.
Like... I feel terrible. I genuinely feel bad about having to do that, but I also have to draw a line..
and doing that, is, it's too far.
It's just too far and.. UGH.. I hate it. Just don't come and this won't be a problem
That's the thing.
Ken: tell her you're sorry and you love her
Alright, well, to the girl that came.. I am sorry if I was mean. but...
And I appreciate that you watch my videos, I guess, I don't know. What do you say?
I appreciate that you found it in your heart to be that excited about potentially seeing me.
Just... I wish your mom would know better.
And tell you 'no, we're not gonna go to his house. That's an invasion of privacy.'
I hate to tell you this...
I filmed all day but I got no- I got no interesting title
What would be the worst thing that we could do? To get a title
Brad: Uhh... Like a hit-by-car vlog type thing.
But not actually getting hit by a car, we'd just fake it?
Brad: Let's come up with a title real quick. what's the title?
Pewds: I got hit by my own car *laughs*
Brad: HIT BY MY OWN CAR!
Pewds:That's pretty good.
Brad: "hit by my own car" is pretty good
Pewds: Would you click on that?
Brad: Hit by car is, like, enough to click, but hit by my OWN car?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
Brad: Alright, How do we do it, do we have to film you? Pewds: Yeah you have to film me..
Brad: being hit by your own car, but NOT
Brad: we just literally lay you down..
Brad: How would Fousey do it? Pewds: How would Fousey do it?
How does this.. look good?
It's gotta look good man! Otherwise no one's gonna click..
Brad: Okay... So basically I just need to film enough into *laughs*
How does this look, by the way?
You gotta get a good frame in!
Brad: I know, I'm trying. It doesn't look like you've been hit by a car. It looks like you've been eaten by a car.
*laughs manically*
Should you take the picture with your phone maybe?
Brad: This looks insane, man
Brad: Like, it just looks really cool, it looks like a music video.
Pewds: That's not.. people don't click on music videos!
Brad: I know! but it looks good
Pewds: DONT DRIVE THE CAR, BRAD!
Brad: If we... had integrity... *trails off*
*Pewds screams like a lil bitch*
Pewds: Oh that's good, oh that's pretty good
Brad: Oh my thumb is in it.  Hang on, do the exact same thing again. Pewds: fucking idiot.
Brad: I can film, I can't do photos.
*pewds screams like a lil bitch again*
Pewds: Okay. I gotta pee so bad, so we gotta finish up fast.
Brad: and that's how you make a youtube video!
Pewds: Thanks fousey!
BIRDABO... what day is it now? 5?
Shit! It goes fast, doesn't it?
I'm having a lot of fun, I hope you bros are enjoying the vlogs,
Leave a like if you do, I really appreciate it, and thank you so much for watching!
and I'll see you tomorrow with another BIRDABO!